right now we had a couple big wins right
we had a big win related to elon getting
twitter that's good we had a big win
related to
uh justice mizell knocking down the mask
mandate on planes we had big wins
related to
desantis fighting the crt stuff here in
florida there was a bunch of big wins
and not only were there big wins but
then there were all these signs that the
democrats are just screwing up
everything with supply chain and
inflation okay fine you guys all get it
but now our eyes off the ball and i'm
gonna do my best to make sure our eye
does not stay off the ball they want us
in a constant shell game never figuring
out what is real and always not thinking
about the right thing so let's go back
and and talk about some of the things
that are not working that they don't
have us talking about right now well how
about inflation saki doesn't think any
of us knew that this was going to happen
we know if we look at the recent
inflation data a large depending on
which data you look at two thirds to
even 70 percent of inflation data is a
result of energy prices a large part of
that is the result and and chairman
powell has spoken to this and secretary
um secretary yellen has also spoken to
this as a result of president putin's
invasion of ukraine and the impact on
the global energy markets those are all
steps and impacts that i don't think
anyone could have predicted a year ago
nonsense everyone could have predicted
it number one number two it's also a lie
like everyone could have predicted
inflation obviously but it's a lie that
this is all because of putin first off
if putin can just decide when we have
inflation or when we don't have
inflation or if any foreign leader can
decide that then then our entire foreign
policy is upside down now that may be
except we know that this isn't because
of putin right first off prices were
going up we've covered this many times
gas prices were already up over a dollar
before the the invasion of ukraine and
do you think if you endlessly print
money
do you think if you just let's say you
have a certain amount of money
and then you have a machine over there
and the machine just starts printing all
of this money and you start giving it to
everybody do you think that the amount
that you had first might start dropping
well that's what they've been doing they
endlessly print
money but don't worry guys joe biden's
here to save us he's very concerned
my top priority is fighting inflation
and lowering prices for families and
things they need today's announcement is
going to give millions of families a
little more a little more breathing room
to help them pay their bills you know we
work with democrats and republicans and
business and non-profits to make this
happen
and we're going to keep working to fight
inflation and lower cost of to all
american families for a lot of other
things as well he's going to keep
working i mean this is the same guy
let's not forget who july 4th of last
year saved you 16 to remember not 16
that would be pretty good saved you 16
cents
16 cents on your july 4th barbecue and
they even put up an image from the
official potus account remember that one
16 cents hey biden i know you're not in
charge and you're just pretending but if
you really wanted people to have more
money in their pocket how about tax cuts
for everybody how about a 25 tax cut
across the board right now but you won't
do that will ya how about we just take
less money from you people in the first
place not gonna do that because that's
not what this really about you can't
pull the wool over my eyes man uh but
now on on a less joking side there are
huge problems that are developing
because of this because we can talk
about oh that you can't get a car right
now and you can't get you know a chair
from creighton barrel or whatever else
now we have a nationwide baby formula
shortage this is real stuff
empty shelves this is really scary and
worried parent a couple stores we've
been in we have not had it we've had to
go to the next location
they are looking for baby formula and
not finding it at least not easily i
myself am down to one can of formula at
the end of april nearly 40 percent of
popular baby formulas were sold out
across the u.s that's up from 31 percent
two weeks before the shortage is getting
worse
this
is a pain about to find baby formula
like many things has been affected by
supply chain issues okay so this is
serious stuff i can tell you as someone
we're about to have two babies and we've
been ordering baby food already we've
been ordering formula already
our first baby's not due till august
second one's not till october and that
just puts more strain because more
people are looking for this stuff but
this is not because of putin this is
because of the ridiculous
buffoons who are in charge of our
government you cannot excuse all of this
stuff